comic book stories are no longer just
marvel and dc's domain
writer mark miller's series jupiter's
legacy got the netflix treatment in 2021
with an eight-episode season after years
of work spent bringing it to life it was
canceled after only one month here's the
untold truth of the short-lived show
when stan lee gives you comic advice you
take it
lee co-created marvel's most iconic
characters but he never owned his own
marvel work which led to a much lower
cut of the prophets from lee's
characters than he deserved
lee even sued marvel in 2002 dismayed
with the meeker cuddy received from the
first spider-man movie
mark miller worked for marvel when lee
encouraged him to break from the company
to create his own content
wanting to help miller avoid the same
mistakes he made lee coached the budding
comic book writer to write for himself
instead of a large company
speaking with business insider in 2015
miller revealed some of the helpful
advice that lee had given him he said
financially now it's so much better for
you guys than it ever was for me
you could own the rights to your own
movies and books you could license this
stuff to people like toys
if i had the opportunity you've had i'd
have killed for it
and with great power comes great
responsibility
no well yeah
given the success that miller has had as
a creator in comics movies and tv
it seems like stanley's advice was worth
listening to
it's not often that a major studio buys
an entire company but that's precisely
what happened with mark miller's miller
world company in 2017 when netflix
bought the whole shebang for around 40
million dollars
of course the acquisition includes all
of miller's comic works from the company
beyond jupiter's legacy including
properties like kick-ass kingsman and
the magic order netflix's first comic
book series which was released after the
company purchased miller world given the
prior success of miller's many works on
screen the purchase doesn't seem to have
been a huge risk for the streaming giant
given that the acquisition happened in
2017 what took so long for the series to
end up on netflix
miller told the hollywood reporter in
april 2021 that he had spent time
focusing more on the series quality
rather than worrying about how quickly
he could get it out saying you can do it
fast or you can do it brilliant
that's my philosophy still heeding stan
lee's advice miller made sure that he
would remain president of miller world
even after the acquisition
in a may 2021 press release about
jupiter's legacy miller noted when my
wife lucy and i sold miller world to
netflix in 2017
our first priority was jupiter's legacy
we had flirted with the idea of a movie
but netflix supported us the chance to
make this adaptation as big and deep as
it needed to be
miller first conceptualized the
jupiter's legacy series in 2008 but the
first issue wasn't published until 2013.
miller handled the words while frank
quietly handled the series illustrations
and pete doherty took on the lettering
as miller told the hollywood reporter
the jupiter's legacy comics are the
longest running series miller has ever
published
spanning over 20 issues the netflix
series covers five issues over a single
eight episode season compared to comic
book universes like dc and marvel eight
years between publishing the first comic
and landing a massive netflix deal for
the series isn't exactly a long wait
time
some comics take decades to get adapted
for the screen so going from the page to
a full-scale film production in that
short a time is far from ordinary of
course it helps that jupiter's legacy is
far from mark miller's first foray into
hollywood
with his resume it was only a matter of
time before jupiter's legacy was added
to his filmography
few directors have had more success with
superhero movies than james gunn
the director brought guardians of the
galaxy to the big screen for the first
time establishing a new beloved
franchise in the marvel film canon he
also picked up the pieces from dc's
suicide squad property with a reimagined
follow-up
2021's a suicide squad so when gunn gave
miller advised about what he should do
with his jupiter's legacy property
miller had good reason to listen while
jupiter's legacy was initially conceived
as a trilogy film series in 2015 with
lorenzo d
bonaventura in a production role miller
discarded the plan with a push from gun
during an interview with denim geek mark
miller revealed that gunn told him that
the comics could never work as a movie
much of miller's success comes from
listening to those who have come before
him and he proved more than willing to
listen to this advice
as miller told den of geek quote the
smartest guy in the world is james gunn
most tv shows with heavy backstory take
an episode or two to lay out the origin
story when delving into the character's
histories but mark miller had other
ideas with jupiter's legacy
instead of spending a minute or 40
delving into the history of the first
superheroes and the jupiter's legacy
canon we get to watch the historical
origins of the union of justice members
be revealed throughout the series one
piece at a time
jumping between past and present the
series dips into its character's great
depression backstory covering their
respective histories when it's relevant
to do so
so what exactly influenced miller to
take this route during an interview with
the rap he revealed that the godfather
part 2 provided the inspiration for the
series woven time jumps
according to miller the idea was pitched
by stephen denying the original
showrunner for jupiter's legacy in the
same way that michael corleone and his
father vito's stories play out at the
same time
decades apart so tooed to the stories of
sheldon and brandon in jupiter's legacy
miller explained the godfather 2
structure shows the father and the son
at the same age
and that's the same thing that's being
done here to show the young characters
and the old characters at the same age
and essentially making the same mistakes
jupiter's legacy has an infinite number
of comic book parallels however the
deepest connection that skyfox actor
matt lanter sees might not be what you'd
expect the actor noted the similarities
between his jupiter's legacy character
and his role as anakin skywalker on star
wars the clone wars
and the outdated rules of conduct that
plagued the heroes of both worlds
lanter chatted with looper during an
exclusive interview where he compared
the rigid nature of the jedi council to
the strict rules of the union and
jupiter's legacy he said the jedi
council seems antiquated and just
doesn't apply in every situation anymore
and the jedi council is so black and
white in its thinking i think anakin
realized that things aren't black and
white
in fact there are shades of grey and
that's exactly what's going on in
jupiter's legacy
in both cases these unwavering rules
lead to the downfall of an otherwise
relatively moral hero the fickle beast
that is mother nature is something that
almost
every series or movie deals with at some
point during shooting when the weather
decides to do something unexpected
production has two options
roll with it or halt production luckily
for jupiter's legacy when the sky's open
for a dramatic snowstorm the weather
only enhanced the scene's otherworldly
quality
during an exclusive interview with
looper cinematographer nicole persh
whitaker
director of photography for several
episodes of jupiter's legacy
revealed the perils of filming in an
unpredictable canadian climate
in one episode in particular the series
is seventh the weather wasn't
cooperating
leading to heavy and unscripted snowfall
while they were shooting a scene in the
woods over the course of a few days
whitaker explained we all went back to
our hotels and woke up in the morning
and there was two feet of snow on the
ground which is very canadian
we were like oh my gosh there's a
snowstorm so basically we got the set
everybody talked about it and decided
this is an island that's alive so let's
embrace it so they started writing and
within an hour we had a new script
luckily for fans a surprise snow lends
an incredibly realistic backdrop to the
scene given that the characters head to
the island to claim their superpowers
they deal with a whole host of
challenges
now including unpredictable weather the
first flashback we get in jupiter's
legacy kicks off the events of the great
depression as the stock market crashes
while it's undoubtedly a fascinating
point in american history it's a unique
time period to place the origin story of
a group of slowly aging superheroes
however the period makes sense given the
year in which miller began writing the
comics
2008 marked a steady economic decline
leading to a financial crisis the likes
of which the world hadn't seen since a
great depression
the death of capitalism that is one hell
of a headline
miller told the hollywood reporter in
april 2021 when i sat down to do this it
was three years before i actually wrote
it during the financial crash in 2008.
i said i'm not going to do this unless i
can make it the greatest superhero story
of all time
setting the superhero's origin stories
in the late 20s with great depression
ties certainly set the story apart from
many of its counterparts
the choice roots the series in a reality
that almost everyone can relate to and
offers a unique vantage point for the
story to cover
as we've seen with the marvel cinematic
universe and dc extended universe
there's no shortage of stories waiting
to be told when film studios decide to
tap into comics characters legacies
with plenty of source material waiting
to be mined jupiter's legacy seemed
poised to enjoy a multiple season run on
netflix but any hopes fans may have had
for follow-up installments were dashed
in early june of 2021 when miller
announced that the cast had been
released from its contracts
although miller indicated that he hadn't
quite given up hope for more jupiter's
legacy on screen at some point in the
short term netflix's decision means the
show has been cancelled
on the bright side this frees miller up
for other projects like the upcoming
supercrook series he's set to debut for
the platform
it's still a bitter pill to swallow for
viewers who came to love the jupiter's
legacy characters throughout the show
but they can always turn to the comics
for more stories the latest chapter of
the saga jupiter's legacy requiem was
already set to begin arriving in comic
shops when the show's cancellation was
announced
so where exactly does miller world and
more specifically jupiter's legacy fall
in the comic book landscape
if you ask matt lanter he'll tell you
that it's the future of comics and
deserves a spot at the top with dc and
marvel
in fact we did ask matt lanter during a
looper exclusive interview
he said i think five years from now
everyone's going to know that it's
miller world it's dc
and it's marvel so i'll get to know
these characters now be the first on the
train and have fun with it man
that's a pretty big claim but it's not
without merit even though the series
isn't moving
forward on netflix the show still made a
huge impression on viewers with a rock
solid debut on the streamer coming in as
the number one program on the platform
upon its release
additionally as far as box office is
concerned miller's 2010 film kick-ass
brought in over 96 million dollars
worldwide and kingsmen the secret
service raked in over 414 million
dollars
those are numbers that are in the range
of or even surpassed some early mcu
projects like captain america the first
avenger which brought in over 370
million dollars
in other words just because jupiter's
legacy may be over on netflix that
doesn't mean it's not still the start of
something big
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one